what have you been up to joey since gone
has been gone
uh a lot of stuff i can't talk about
okay yeah but uh i hung out with uh nano
the other day oh yeah i saw that yeah
yeah nice like uh she wanted to hang out
and uh we went to karaoke and apparently
she hasn't gone to karaoke in like 15
years what well that's her life yeah
because like she sings for a job she
goes like she's still i mean she's just
like unavoidable yeah right she just
goes to karaoke on stage and in the
studio right and then she sang and then
we got like you know we we sang a bunch
of songs and then i was like can you
sing one of your songs just jokingly
yeah yeah because you know she has her
songs on karaoke so it's like you have
to seize that opportunity of course of
course and she's like i've never sung my
own songs at karaoke before
and so i thought that was going to be
like a no yeah that was like a nice way
of her saying no
she then proceeds to put in like
literally every song
you're like i got a concert yeah amazing
i basically just got a free concert
maybe no one asked her before no
one had the ghoul
she's like i've been waiting for someone
to ask me this my entire life joey the
audacity of this guy to ask
no but she was really [ __ ] cool and
like we got to hang out and like we're
going to hang out a lot more um yeah
other than that i've just been like
yeah every day i've just been like
hanging out with someone different nice
yeah that's always fun yeah just going
out and uh yeah it's been good it's uh
being sociable again and you know after
the pandemic has been really nice
have you had a chance to hang out with
aki a lot because there's a lot of
things we can't talk about but one thing
i will say is that joey didn't get to
see a lot of vacuum last month no i
think i saw her for like a week
maybe so uh she was like you know yeah
let's hang out a little more and i was
like yeah we should probably do that
i did i did though i did
we hung out a lot um like we we go like
uh like kind of like once a week dates
just to like you know nearby places just
like hanging out and stuff and uh yeah
it's really good um oh yeah i've i've
discovered like
a lot of tokyo in this past week i think
really just because i've been going out
to like all sorts of different places
all sorts of different people so it's
like you know there's like i was in
shibuya just yesterday for uh my friend
luke's birthday
and like we went to like all these new
places like i've never been before like
we were in like areas of shirya where i
was like oh this is
and it's just so weird that like tokyo
is one of those places where it's like
it's everything is just so like
tight-knit and like kind of hidden that
there are just entire areas of cities
you've probably never seen before yeah
yeah and he's like oh oh this place
exists and this is kind of cool yeah my
google maps is [ __ ] because i've saved
so many restaurants and bars i like yeah
yeah i like
none of them mean anything now because i
don't know which one is wood like you
literally have to [ __ ] yeah i'm trying
to remember a bar i'm like there's no
search function so yeah i'm literally
i'm like i think it was this area and
i'm just checking all my hearts in that
area yeah yeah and i'm like okay great
it's none of the [ __ ] these great
yeah i'm [ __ ]
there's no way to categorize i've
actually started doing that now because
i didn't do that before but because when
you go to so many different places and
you're trying to record that one place
in tokyo right right right it's like the
hardest [ __ ] city because like in
most other cities you can be like what
is this bar and you like type in the
description of the bar you're like great
there's only one bar in this area it's
like five minutes away you type in like
the vague description in like tokyo and
like seven different bars pop up you're
like it was one of these i think i don't
even know if i'm describing it right you
know it's great because like you know
like when emily and dad has just moved
here it's like all right what food do
you want i have i have a i have a thing
for that yeah what bond what kind of bar
vibe do you want all right i've got like
three of each kind yeah oh we're in this
area okay we'll go to this one i have i
have a thing like i've saved like
everything so i've got every kind of
restaurant every kind of vibe you'd want
yeah so i've got i've got a bunch so
it's fantastic but like it's become so
extensive now is that you're just like
okay so you're going for a specific vibe
yeah specific food i know like eight
places
yeah which one of these eight places do
you want yeah then it's like all right
how expensive do you want okay all right
now do you wanna be like five minute
walk from the station town walking
station okay we're gonna go this far
afterwards though is that okay with you
yeah it's like all right okay okay i'm
still trying to find more as well yeah
so many places i'll never i'll never get
to see them all yeah honestly yeah like
even just like in shibuya like there's
just so many places to just eat or drink
out they're like
you could go out every night to like a
bar yeah like it's somewhere different
in just in shibuya and it'll probably
take you like years yeah like one one
thing i definitely noticed going back to
the uk for two weeks i did is that i've
definitely taken for granted how easy it
is to find somewhere to stay out late in
japan i've like forgotten about that in
um in the uk because you know it's 12
and yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah impossible yeah he hits 12 and like
every bar closes every pub closes so the
only place that's like
that you can viably go to basically is a
uh is a club most of the time i don't
want to go clubbing you know i don't
want to go to club i want to continue
the conversation i'm having so i've
definitely gotten used to in japan you
hit up like the karaoke or there's this
one bar that's open until like 4 a.m or
there's so many places open until late
and i've forgotten that in the uk he
hits 12 and you like try to google where
the next place to go to is and there's
nothing there is just nothing you just
come out blank and you're like well [ __ ]
we gotta keep this going somehow right
and uh there's just no options available
unfortunately uk sucks for that i do
remember that yeah every night at 12
it's like all right [ __ ] we have to
really look to find a place yeah it's
just like someone went to like the the
power bank it just went right
everything just goes down
like an apocalypse on sundays like shop
shut like four p.m what well like just
like supermarkets yeah really yeah or
some places just don't even open oh i
mean like i get the don't even open but
like what's the point of like being open
for like five hours i think i think i
think london has laws of like on sunday
a shop can only remain open for x amount
of hours so they choose like the busiest
hours from like 10 till last oh i see i
can't remember what the exact hours were
i know at least where uh where i lived
in london it was that rule yeah so all
the shops shot and opened at the same
time on sundays yeah yeah i mean it's
it's kind of being like that right now
like with uh it being golden week yeah
yeah and like when i was hanging out
with nana like we were trying to find
like a lunch place yeah and it's either
it's either it's closed during golden
week right or it's got like 200 capacity
yeah
if you come to japan try and avoid this
period because uh hotels and flights and
everything is like oh my god i saw like
pictures of like
like honeydew airport oh gosh this week
it is a nightmare yeah because it's
basically the only week off that most
working japanese people have like where
they have a full week off yeah so they
all travel they all go to hotels so yeah
trying to avoid this week if you come to
japan yeah because it's it's it's rammed
it is it's the week where every manga
chapter takes a week off yeah that's how
you know that's how i remember is that
is that actually that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah because i was just like i was
i remember like you know i remember
growing up and being like man naruto one
piece and bleach are taking a break on
like the same week what's going on
what's going i need to know what's
happening man that's how manga readers
tell the time they're like oh oda's
taking a week off it must be gold
yeah because it's not only like that
bars closed as well like i forget you
know combinies are a thing here so if
you need access to alcohol if you're
going brandon mate's house whatever
you've always got the company but like
you want to go to a tescos or a
sainsburys or something you better hope
that you plan ahead and you get it
before like 11 which is yeah some places
close at 11 and that's like the latest
at some places closes it's just like
double the price of the outflow because
you're a corner store that's shitty and
they make all their money from up
charging alcohol yeah but even like
there are some corner stores you go to
especially in london where you know it's
open but they don't serve alcohol past
12. so it's it's it's like well [ __ ] man
you you literally have no options so but
i discovered that the other day when i
was like coming home late and it was
like you know last train and stuff and i
was like oh man feeling a bit hungry
like might just like pop over to a
mcdonald's just do a quick little maccas
run before i yeah and it was like 1am
right and the mcdonald's are still open
i was like oh sick amazing let's go in
so i walk in and the guy is like dorinku
only what and i was like
who the [ __ ] is walking into a
mcdonald's to get a drink look i'll
close the sign for you bro yeah like
literally why you walk down dude
[Music]
from like the drinks to like warren
staying open only for drinks i mean i i
thought it was a bit weird being like oh
okay it's still open but there's no one
in here right now
so now i know so you don't know your
target audience if you're at 1am and
you're serving drinks only
what the [ __ ] like there isn't like a
special drink that's only served at
mcdonald's you know yeah
there's only one reason i'm going to
mcdonald's at 1am it's a smash of
[ __ ] yeah it's like give me a [ __ ]
burger yeah you want to smash your
burger smashing a burger or like
ordering those 20 nugs which you would
never order except at 1am at a
mcdonald's like i'm not here to smash an
orange juice at a mcdonald's at 1am like
i can do that anywhere i always get the
milk
i only exclusively drink
milk i'll
squeeze